mais ce sont des enfants et vous vous
n'êtes qu'un traducteur
[Musique]
béchard
salut moment ça va manquer
via universal mon chéri c'est en indoor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux avoir affaire à moi tu es castan
mauviette y aura la place
[Applaudissements]
angel ubot jessica plus près les parler
du bateau arrive ça espèce de gros nuls
où tu m'as avoir à faire alors est ce
que j'ai vraiment entendu ça où j'ai
rêvé de la nourriture on partage
technique toi que je suis à le gagner je
vais mourir et ce à cause de toi vous à
vouloir me dû affronter problème c'est
impossible ce papa tu étais d c'est
notre terrain de jeu on a construit avec
odyssée je confierais pas ma maison j'ai
promis de t d et toi de faire de même en
retour
c'est fini
lassant la bouche yeux
c
au chili peppers min est un monstre
il exploite des enfants pour fabriquer
ses jouets tout d'abord je suis ton
nouveau meilleur ami
ça
c'est en mai